faisons un bond à la fois dans l'espace
est aussi dans le temps puisque je vous
convie à me suivre maintenant le 8
novembre 1939 à berlin à munich plutôt à
munich à l'as bürger brao keller 8
novembre 1939 dans cette très grande
brasserie de munich 3000 nazis sont
réunis oui c'est une salle les normes et
ses nazis sont réunis pour attendre bien
sûr
adolf hitler car c'est une tradition
tous les ans le 8 9 ans hitler vient
parler à la bürger brao keller et là le
rejoigne ce qu'on appelle les vieux
combattant les anciens du parti ce qui
était la première heure et hocine bien
sûr les dignitaires actuelle du régime
pourquoi ce 8 novembre pourquoi tous les
8 novembre et bien parce que le 8
novembre 1923 hitler qui n'était encore
qu'un agitateur obscures aux yeux de
beaucoup
hitler essayer son premier coup d'état
son premier putsch le putsch de la
brasserie il tirait un coup de revolver
dans le plafond essayer de faire
prisonnier une partie des autorités de
munich il échoué et plus tard ce fut le
la marche sur le centre de munich est
clair et le dender of la police qui tire
le chèque des morts des blessés
l'échec oui mais quand même l'élan vers
autre chose parce que paradoxalement
hitler fait parler lui plus qu'il n'a
jamais fait parler lui à propos de cet
échec
et quand il est rejugé il prend le
tribunal comme prétoire qu'il parle à
l'allemagne entière comme s'il était
devant un public
il devient
célèbre et quand il sera en prison dans
une forteresse c'est là qu'il écrira
mein kampf
c'est là qu'il fixera la doctrine du
parti c'est donc un moment capital de
l'histoire du nazisme et c'est pour ça
que tous les ans le 8 novembre les vieux
combattant retrouve est clair ils sont
là et sont là en 1939 le vix novembre
3000 avec évidemment un climat tout
particulier parce que 39 inutile le
faire comme on dit à dessein 39 c'est
l'apogée 39,7 aussi bien d'abord
l'entrée sans coup férir donc sans coup
férir à prague
c'est 39 le pacte d'acier
c'est le pacte germano soviétique
c'est la pologne écrasé en trois
semaines c'est tout cela et maintenant
hitler qui va parler
et d'ailleurs le voilà le voilà qui
entre dans la vie regard brao quelle
heure il passe rapidement dans la salle
cependant qu'une immense ovation
l'accueil il a l'air sombre
tous les témoins disent qu'il a l'air
concentré il part il monte à la tribune
qui a été préparé et il commence à
parler le thème c'est bien sûr le rappel
du passé la marche du parti
ce point de départ et c'est arrivé
fulgurante et oui des d'hitler qui
aurait cru que nous pourrions arriver
jusque là dominé l'europe faire la loi
au monde et les paroles et le flux le
flou at war qui continue et bien sûr la
guerre j'ai proposé la paix j'ai proposé
la paix à l'angleterre et la france
qu'elle accepte car si elles
n'acceptaient pas il n'y aura qu'un
vainqueur à savoir nous est alors
saint-élie
un délire d'acclamations et on a glissé
un papier sur le pupitre d'hitler
justement il profite de ce moment de cet
interlude si j'ose dire pour lire le
papier
et puis il continue l'envolée le
rappelle la fidélité et les grands
thèmes nous devons tous être fidèle à
commencer par moi et nous devons savoir
que notre sang appartient la batterie
allemands et c'est la péroraison
[Musique]
camarades du parti
vive le mouvement national socialiste
vive le peuple allemand et vivent
aujourd'hui surtout notre armée
victorieuse applaudissements
acclamations il descend de la tribune il
et 20h58 il était monté à la tribune à
20h08
il a donc parle exactement cinquante
minutes et c'est curieux c'est curieux
parce qu'en général il parle au moins
une heure et demie et là il l'a
visiblement abrégé et on s'étonne déjà
et alors qu'en général ils restent dans
la brasserie un long moment allant de
tables en tables serrant des mains
plaisantant avec tel ou tel vieux
compagnons là il passe très vite s'en va
il est 21h 9
quand il quitte la brasserie il monte en
voiture par pour la gare il est 21
heures 24
quand il arrive à la gare de munich
21h27 quand il monte dans son wagon
salon et le train part pour berlin 21h30
et or
à 20h20 très précisément une immense
déflagration avait secoué la brasserie
de la burgue arbres tout avait volé en
éclats dans la salle heureusement
plusieurs la plus grande partie de la
foule
déçu par le départ brusque et d'hitler
l'avait suivi il ne restait plus que
quelques dizaines de personnes des
gardes du parti des fonctionnaires des
policiers est aussi le personnel de la
brasserie et laon recettes mort 63
blessés et le train et le train qui
roule dans la nuit
le wagon salon hit l'air détendu parce
que heatley cette hyper nerveux
hitler est facilement tendu il était
sombre en arrivant bien là nous il l'est
plus il est calme parce que la décharge
nerveuse et bien il l'a laissée là dans
son discours alors on plaisante autour
de lui le dr goebbels et la raconte des
histoires on boit on boit de l'alcool
car c'est encore permis de boire de
l'alcool auprès du führer bientôt ce
sera interdite puis voilà le trac qui
s'arrête à nuremberg goebbels qui
descendent du train et qui va aux
nouvelles qui va porter des messages
qu'on envoie par télégraphe ou par
téléphone et qui vient recevoir d'autres
messages s'il en est et qui remonte dans
le train il est livide et il annonce au
führer l'attentât auquel il a échappé
d'abord il plaire un moment de doute
est-ce une plaisanterie nom que belge
donne des détails et hitler laisse
éclater sa fureur et pourtant qui se
reprend et il dit la providence veiller
sur moi et il dira un peu plus tard il
dira un peu plus tard à une de ses
secrétaires qui en a témoigné qu'il l'a
noté je ne sais quelle force obscure m'a
poussé pendant que je parlais
une force qui me poussait à abréger et
je comprends maintenant la providence
veille sur moi la providence prouve
qu'elle protège ma destinée alors le
train continue dans cette nuit et cette
nuit qui est troublé par des coups de
téléphone car la nouvelle cour les fils
téléphoniques de l'allemagne à 22 heures
le président de la police criminelle
deux berlin arthur neb achève de dîner
le téléphone sonne et c'était driessche
qui la paix reinhard heydrich le
tout-puissant rheinhardt hedrich le chef
de toutes les polices de tous les
services secrets nazis
ss reinhard heydrich qui annonce aneb
l'événement et qui lui dit nm note que
la voix de heydrich est affolée hedrich
qui dit aneb il faut former cette nuit
même une commission d' enquête spéciale
et vous devez partir demain à l'aube
pour medic et un peu plus tard dans la
nuit c'est valter schellenberg qui est à
düsseldorf qui le chagrine berck c'est
le chef du contre espionnage nazi il
dort lui il est en train de nouer une
intrigue extraordinaire avec des agents
secrets britanniques beste stevens des
hommes de l'intelligence service est ce
qu a monté le service de shell enberg
c'est une intoxication les services
britanniques ont leur fait croire qu'ils
sont en train de rencontrer des membres
de l'opposition allemande alors qu'en
fait ce sont des agents nazis qu'ils
rencontrent et schoenberg et
l'ajustement à düsseldorf non loin de la
frontière pour veiller sur
l'organisation de ce vaste plan lorsque
il est réveillé au téléphone et 7
himmler et oui le reichsführer ss
heinrich himmler
qui l'eût dit schellenberg on a tenté on
a voulu attenter à la vie du führer le
führer et dieu merci dieu soit loué sain
et sauf mais le führer sait déjà que
ceux qui ont un âge ils l'ont fait à
l'instigation de l'intelligence service
assurément beste steven ce sont les
agents qui ont tout organisé il faut les
arrêter mais des chaînes berg ils sont
en territoire hollandais qu'on viole la
frontière hollandaise d'himmler qui
n'est pas à ça près c'est un ordre et
celle enberg voit s'écrouler en un
instant toute cette affaire à laquelle
on avait travaillé pendant les semaines
et en effet on va franchir la frontière
hollandaise et on va enlever
littéralement best et stevens
le lendemain matin le 9 novembre à
l'aube n'est bay prend son avion l'avion
qui l'attend hedrich est à côté de lui
idriss qui a le regard et ne dira aneb
heydrich qui le félicite et le félicite
pourquoi parce que hitler a nommé n'est
bon chef de la commission denquête c'est
lui qui a qui domine tout l'anc est sur
l'attentât alors que heydrich aurait
voulu que ce fût heinrich muller de la
gestapo
alors je vous félicite et riche vous
savez c'est un monde étrange un monde où
ces gens là se haïssent de service un
service toute l'explication du national
socialisme et là dedans
des rivalités impitoyable des haines
inexpiables et des petitesses de
petitesse incroyable et dans l'avion
dans l'avion qui vole vers munich nebe
réfléchi et se dit mais enfin qu'est ce
que c'est que cette affaire l'attentât
d'un isolé presque impossible alors un
complot mais quel complot serait ce des
opposants allemands des exilés comme
auto strasser et son fond noir serait ce
au contraire à l'intérieur des
militaires allemands carnet ben c'est
comme plusieurs le savent qu'il y à une
opposition sur dans l'armée allemande et
que présentement des généraux allemands
complotent contre il est alors est-ce
que ce complot qu'il n'est resté jusque
là quand parole est-ce que ce complot
aurait débouché sur une action est ce
que les militaires auraient voulu se
débarrasser vite l'air ça n'est pas
impossible
est-ce que encore il s'agirait
d'une action interne à la gestapo tout
est possible d'une provocation
on l'a tous vu dans l'allemagne nazie
alors qu'il ne sait pas et s'il
débouchait par hasard sur l'entourage de
l'amiral 'canaris' le chef des services
secrets de l'abwehr de l'armée pas de
l'abwehr de l'armée justement de la
wehrmacht s'il débouchait sur cet
entourage alors que devrait il faire
il sent qu'il est tombé dans une sorte
de piège que la tâche de éclair lui a
donné une tâche redoutable
l'avion arrive et dès l'abord nébing à
munich décide de former deux groupes d'
enquêtes l'une l'un qu'il dirigera
lui-même pour éclaircir les
circonstances de l'attentât
l'autre qu'il confiera à une riche
muller de la gestapo pour essayer de
trouver le ou les auteurs et il se met
au travail et pour cela il part tout de
suite immédiatement vers la burgue rbra
au caire
hélas ce qu'il découvre le stupéfie
parce que ce n'est qu'un amas de
décombres
cette grande salle avec sa galerie à
voler en éclats les poutrelles pente
les tables sont déchiquetés les fenêtres
les portes les banquettes les chaises
il s'approche et il cherche l'endroit de
la tribune et cette tribune il n'y a
plus rien plus rien plus rien si hitler
avait parlé au moment où la bombe ou la
machine infernale avait éclaté il clair
aurait été réduit en un amas presque
insaisissable sort était n'aurait pas
trouvé dira plus tard quelqu'un avec un
certain humour on n'aurait même pas
retrouvé sa moustache
alors il faut chercher
et les criminalistes deneb cherche déjà
ils cherchent dans les ruines et il
commence à découvrir déjà elles ont déjà
découvert des morceaux de l'étang tordu
des morceaux de liège des morceaux de
toutes sortes de choses
et grâce à cela grâce à cela ils peuvent
coller sur des cartons sur des tables
sur des panneaux de bois
ils peuvent coller les pièces à
conviction ils peuvent montrer aneb déjà
quelques fragments de la bombe de la
machine infernale
alors ces fragments mais bon les
examiner c'est sur ces fragments clan
quête commence immédiatement
il y a visiblement des fragments
d'horloge il y à des fragments de liège
donc qui ont été vendus par un
spécialiste part dans un magasin
spécialisé et immédiatement passe comme
on dit au peigne fin toute la ville de
munich tous les horlogers tous les
cahiers etc etc etc et dans l'après midi
ça a été très vite très belle enquête et
dans l'après midi
on la porte déjà les rapports à ned un
homme jeune d'une trentaine d'années
acheté chez un horloger deux horloges
pas une chose qui arrive tous les jours
et l'horloger s'en souvient et les
mécanismes dont on a retrouvé des débris
ces mécanismes correspondent aux
horloges qui ont été vendus il vendeurs
l'horloger se souvient que ce jeune
homme
cet homme jeune avec un fort accent
souabe un serrurier à serrurier se
souvient d'avoir prêté son atelier un
jeune homme qui avait besoin de
travailler une invention disait-il
et ce jeune homme avait un très fort
accent souabe un quincaillier a vendu
des morceaux de liège qui correspondent
à ce qu'on l'a trouvé et celui à qui il
les a vendus à un axe avait un accent
souabe et enfin à la bure gheerbrant
keller le
personnel se souvient d'un homme jeune
qui est venu très très souvent et qu'il
y avait un très fort accent souabe
alors voilà ce que présente neb heydrich
à müller plutôt l'agent des deux riches
je lui dis à vous de jouer
vous avez arrêté déjà quelques centaines
de suspects car le fait muller avait
arrêté à tour de bras n'étaient pas à ça
près on avait même requis une trentaine
de royalistes comme ça pour faire bien
alors est ce que dans votre gibier il y
à un homme jeune à l'accent souabe
et bien oui il l'avait c'est là que
l'imagination tout à coup se met à ceux
des bruits dire se dire si c'est pas
vrai mais s'ils n'avaient pas l'homme il
avait un câble au gras qui était venue
d'un poste frontière à frontière suisse
pas le constance et qui disait ceci nous
avons arrêté hier soir à 20h20
près du poste frontière un homme qui
visiblement tenté de franchir la
frontière suisse et cet homme portait un
insigne du parti communiste du front
rouge
il avait sur lui un détonateur et enfin
de carte postale montrant la grande
salle de la bürger brao keller et sur le
pilier où avait été placée la bombe il y
avait une croix
cet homme s'appelait georg elser il
était né à irma ring and en levure
timbert c'est-à-dire au coeur du pays
souabe immédiatement message à la faune
dire qu'on en voit ses gains se tenait
ben qui regarde ça qui regardent ce
câble au g cette humeur face et c'est
trop beau c'est vraiment trop beau et et
voyons vous et moi on se dit la même
chose face un homme qui fait un attentat
et qui une carte postale sur lui pour
bien prouver qu'il a faits l'attentât
avec une croix sur le pilier on a mis la
bombe
cet homme qui se fait arrêter à la
frontière avec en plus un détonateur
et puis un insigne du parti communiste
pour tout arranger en 39 en allemagne et
nous sommes conem nous attendons le
lendemain avec impatience le lendemain
il est là georg et n'est bas rive et le
regarde et nous le regardons avec lui
il est là devant lui et c'est un homme
qui apparaît à nay bhl contraire d'un
terminus à base d'un n'hallucinez pas de
tous est un homme sorte de paysans
solide francs regard direct sympathique
et cet homme-là c'est très exactement ce
qu'il dit ce qu'il fait et n'est blanc
et rouge et l'autre nie absolument je
n'étais pas à la burgue rbra au keller
d'ailleurs le 8 ch était à constance
j'ai un alibi et c'est vrai d'un alibi
et par ailleurs je ne suis coupable de
rien sommes donc le 10 le 11
hitler arrive à munich
hitler arrive à munich pour assister aux
obsèques pour présenter aux familles des
victimes ses condoléances s'il assiste à
de cérémonie et ensuite s'en va
directement à la burgue rbra auquel
aires où il va lui aussi s'étonner
devant l'énormité de la déflagration
il s'approchera du pilier et demandera
aneb d'après vos services combien de
temps pour creuser à la cavité qui avait
d'anti qui existait dans ce pilier mein
führer 200 heures de travail au moins
200 heures de travail alors c'est un
groupe alors il faut chercher une aide
il faut chercher du côté d'auto strasser
auto strasser l'ennemi d'hitler l'homme
qui après avec avoir été son ami avec
gregor strasser depuis que son frère
grégory sera serre a été tué paris
clercs lors de la nuit des longs
couteaux auto strasser qui est devenu
l'ennemi juré heatley et quitte en exil
et qui parle à la radio h à strasbourg
aux touches tracèrent qui en effet
essayé de tuer par trois fois adolf
hitler
il faut chercher de ce côté là et hitler
s'en va mais himmler lui et là il reste
himmler veille sur l' enquête puisque
hitler a parlé de complicité pour
himmler c'est un dogme et neb a beau
dire mais vous savez il s'agit pourtant
semble-t-il d'une bombe très artisanal
si ce sont des étrangers si c'est un
complot si ce sont les anglais et bien
il reste le même matériel plus plus
accompli non et ils appellent
immédiatement un médium le médium le
plus célèbre de vienne qui arrivent et
des bassistes à cette scène incroyable
de himmler en extase devant le médium
qui naturellement entre en transe et qui
voit tout de suite je vois je vois sur
les bords d'un lac
un homme qui s'appelle otto mai puis je
vois je vois auto dans un train et dans
une gare il reçoit un très grand colis
et puis auto je vois je vois je ne vois
plus je ne vois plus il faudrait il
faudrait que j'aie un objet un objet de
la brasserie vite dit moulay ahmed al
objet quelque chose qu'on la retrouvera
là-bas à la brasserie vite vite vite à
fra
la bombe net passe à côté il ya pas
vraiment la bombe lui prend n'importe
quoi la porte à une muller aux messins
entre les mains du médium quignard oui
maintenant je vois je vois très bien aux
taux qui arrive à la porte devant une
fenêtre
c'est une brasserie c'est une brasserie
et puis alors on casse une fenêtre ils
rentrent il est avec deux hommes et il
pose le colis dans un pays alors là
aiment la dose en prie vous voyez est le
médium qui dit salah se passe dans la
nuit du 7 au 8 alors une heure là
vraiment que ne le plus beau jour de sa
vie
nev n'ose pas lui dire que c'est
impossible parce que dans la nuit du 7
au 8
il y avait des gardes ss or toute la
nuit qui était là alors
alors simplement neb dira i'm l'air
qu'il y a des choses étranges entre le
ciel et la terre et müller dire un
espace ned neige n'aura pas le courage
de dire que c'est une citation de
shakespeare mais pendant qu'ils
écoutaient son médium himmler le perdez
pas de temps il faisait interrogée enfin
elle sert par des spécialistes de la
gestapo des spécialistes jeu mais le mot
entre guillemets il trouvait que les
interrogatoires deneb n'était pas assez
disons efficace alors il avait des
hommes sous la main et cette fois elle
sert à vous est alors ces
interrogatoires existent ils sont même
aux archives d'état à coblence et andré
brisseau vous connaissez tous les
travaux sur le nazisme
andré brisson les a retrouvés là les a
commentés et il faut les suivre ces
interrogatoires
c'est le récit d'elle c'est réel c'est
requête qu'il raconte elle sert raconte
que son frère qui était communiste a été
arrêté sur l'ordre des nazis et jeté
dans le camp de daran et la lcr à
juraient de venger son frère alors il a
juré qu'il tuerait il est comment et
bien il a réfléchi et l'idée lui est
venue puisque claire venait chaque année
le 8 novembre la burger bras au calm air
et bien c'est la culture et hitler il
fabriquerait une bombe qu'il déposerait
non loin de l'endroit où parler
traditionnellement le führer et c'est ce
qu'il fait et la préparation de
l'attentât a duré 18 mois il faut
admirer ces leveaux il faut admirer
cette patience est extraordinaire
persévérant cet homme qui peu à peu près
par 100 l'a fait n'oubliant aucun détail
il s'engage d'abord dans une poudrerie
et là il va pouvoir voler de la poudre
et des explosifs
ensuite il s'engage comme manoeuvre dans
une carrière et là il peut voler des
pains d'explosif
et puis aussi des détonateurs alors à
pâques 1939 il arrive à munich il vient
examiner les lieux vient plusieurs fois
la bière guerre brao keller enquête
découvre l'endroit très exact wikler a
l'habitude de parler la tribune ne varie
pas c'est toujours au même endroit
au début de l'été 39 il éprouve ses
explosifs dans le jardin de son oncle à
aire marine gun et l'oncle croit
défaillir on entendait tout à coup une
immense explosion il témoigné leur
témoignera d'ailleurs plus d'un en tout
cas les explosifs sont bons et puis au
moins 12 39
il vient s'installer à munich et là nous
avons les témoignages de ces quatre
logeuse qui parle de lui avec beaucoup
d'éloges c'est un jeune homme tranquille
qui ne voient pas de femmes simplement
c'est très curieux surtout dans les
derniers temps et bien dans les derniers
temps il arrive toujours à la maison
très tard et même plutôt très tôt
puisqu'il arrive à l'ombre et puis que
fait l air est bien ce que nous avions
déjà puisque qu'il nomme les mêmes gens
que la police avait déjà découvert il
nomme le serrurier qui lui a prêté son
atelier c'est une preuve de plus il
nomme un marchon d'outils qui lui a
également prêté un établi il nomme
différentes personnes grâce auquel a
directement il a pu fabriquer sa bombe
et puis enfin sa bombe étant achevé il
est venu chaque soir à la belle guerre
brao keller
chaque soir il arrivé vers 22 heures en
général prenez presque toujours la même
chose deux petites saucisses et puis des
choux une petite bière brune et il
parlait souvent avec la serveuse et il
semble même qu'il se soit étroitement
lié avec cette serveuse qui d'ailleurs
devait disparaître dans l'est
jauzion et puis là tant la fermeture est
là il passe aux toilettes s'enferment
dans les toilettes il attend que tous
dorment dans la brasserie quand tout le
monde est parti quand toutes les
lumières sont éteintes quand toutes les
portes sont bouclés il ça et là va
creuser soigneusement son pilier pilier
bien repéré il a une valise toujours qui
ne le quitte pas une vieille valise
noire
il met les gravats dans cette valise et
à l'aube quand il a fini de creuser
eh bien il s'en va il va jeter les
gravats dans les arts la rivière qui
coule non loin de là et il viendra la de
30 à 35 jours jamais surpris sauf une
fois une fois ils étaient dans les
toilettes lorsque le propriétaire fait
un dernier tour arrive dans les
toilettes des médias quelqu'un oui oui
ouvrez mois ouvre et moi criaient les
uns on m'a enfermée
j'étais venu soigner mon furoncle et
c'est vrai il un gros furan qu'il était
venu le soigner dit il alors le
propriétaire est tous contents
malheureusement j'ai fait un dernier
tour ils l'accompagnent et relatant le 3
novembre la cavité prête elle à 80
centimètres carrés et il y dépose la
bombe
la nuit suivante il la gare ni
d'explosif et dans la nuit du 5 au 6
novembre
il règle le mouvement d'horloge il faut
que ce mouvement se déclenche dans trois
jours très exactement entre 21h15 et
21h30 et le sel c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est très exactement ce qui s'est passé
disons que pour un homme qui deux sont
les tailles n'était pas horloger il
était menuisier ébéniste qui de son
l'état n'était pas en loger c'est une
bouée alors la suite on la connaît il
part il quitte munich arrive à constance
va le soir du 8 franchir la frontière
il connaît en effet non loin d'un poste
de douane un sentier où il n'y a jamais
de douaniers où il va pouvoir passer et
il racontera qu'il avait sur lui la
carte postale est le détonateur parce
qu'il voulait
demander l'asile politique à la suisse
et se fait reconnaître en disant c'est
moi l'homme de la tentative pour
regarder voilà j'ai la carte postale est
alors tout à coup il entend par la
fenêtre ouverte du poste de douane la
radio et c'est hitler qui parle qui
parle ou à la bürger brao keller c'est
en direct et imaginé cet homme qui va
filer en suisse et la vis aux c'est la
liberté et qui entend la voix de l'homme
qu'il a décidé de tuer qui sait qu'une
machine est là à côté de cet homme qui
parle une machine qui va exploser dans
un instant et il est littéralement
fasciné il s'arrête et au lieu d'aller
vers la suisse il s'approche du poste de
douane il écoute il écoute
jusqu'au moment où humains se pose sur
son épaule
c'est un douanier qu'est ce que vous
faites pas ici si vous rentriez dans le
poste de douane on en parlait alors
l'interrogatoire est lui qui n'écoutent
que la radio et qui entend tout à coup
quitte l'air achevé camarades du parti
vive notre armée victorieuse les
acclamations
le speaker qui annonce que c'est fini et
la bombe qui n'a pas explosé le
désespoir
le lendemain munich voilà le récit des
éclairs mettra beaucoup de temps à
admettre que il n'y a pas de lien entre
best stevens et elle sait best stevens
sera envoyé dans un camp de
concentration
et elle sert encore interrogé longuement
parce que la presse déjà veut accréditer
le mythe d'un complot et pourtant
d'après le récit qu'on a c'est un homme
seul
alors la presse veut accréditer le mythe
d'un complot et tous les journaux qui
paraît ces jours là parlent de
l'intelligence service parle aussi de
strasser et d'ailleurs nous possédons
ici un un journal un journal que nous
tenons de monsieur victor alexandrov de
sa collection personnelle qui est un
exemplaire authentique du voltigeur
beobachter
l'observateur du peuple et vous voyez le
type
auto strasser darksiders grichting et
anne dienst on mettait à la fois les
anglais et strasser dans le coup et
pourtant on savait déjà
en fait que les anglais n'étaient pas
dans le coup on l'avait interrogé elle
sert par des psychiatres
on lui avait fait des piqûres de
pervertir qui diminue la volonté même
sous perverti ni lavé continue à
raconter la même chose et puis ensuite
on l'avait fait une haute idée ça
c'était team l'air bien sûr sa vieille
marotte 3 hypnotiseur avait échoué le
quatrième l'avait réussi à le mettre
sous état hypnotique et la soute état
hypnotique il avait raconté la même
chose alors elle sert avait été envoyé
lui aussi dans un camp de concentration
et on se posait tout de même encore
beaucoup de questions dans certains
milieux allemands quelle question est
bien la question de savoir si elle sert
avait dit ou non la vérité s'il avait ou
non agi seul
et on se souvenait tout de même de ce
discours d'hitler
si abrégé pourquoi n'avait-il parler que
50 minutes et pas une heure et demie on
se souvenait du billet qu'on lui avait
passé pendant le disco et on se disait
mais voilà tout de même bien les
précautions habitudes même hitler avait
dit oui une force une force inconnue m'a
forcé à abréger alors on réfléchit c'est
là dessus et pourtant on avait tort de
réfléchi parce qu'il clerc avait menti
nous savons aujourd'hui que s'il est il
avait abrégé c'est pour une raison
précise
il y avait un rendez-vous le lendemain
matin à 10h à berlin il était venu en
avion et berlin à munich et à son pilote
bord il avait dit pouvez-vous me
promettre de me ramener demain matin
pour que je sois 10h à berlin et non
avait dix bornes on a une fureur il ya
des brumes en novembre je ne sais pas
s'il fait beau temps oui c'est pas beau
temps non eh bien je prendrai le train
avait dit et nous avons le témoignage de
bord et nous avons le témoignage de la
secrétaire dit mme lahaye qui raconte
que l'après midi même himmler lui
annoncer qu'il clair les pris la
décision de prendre le train de faire
simplement rattacher son wagon salon à
l'express munich berlin qui partait à
21h31 c'était pour être à la gare à
21h31 qu'il avait bâclé son discours
elle souvenez-vous qu'il était arrivé en
effet à 21h24 etc à 21h27 il était dans
son wagon salon donc la providence le le
mouvement irrésistible tout ça c'est
faux alors par ailleurs
la gestapo il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui
encore dans certains milieux proches de
l'abwehr et ses confidences ont été
recueillis notamment par lucien corrosif
on est persuadé dans des milieux proches
de l'amiral 'canaris' également on est
persuadé que c'est la gestapo qui a fait
le coup
alors peut-être sans l'aveu dit lei mais
alors en organisant un coup monté de
manière à ce que l'attentât échoué pour
des raisons de propagande pour
galvaniser le peuple allemand est en
effet le tout les commentaires de la
presse a l'air dans ce sens un moment où
il y avait des grandes décisions à
prendre la guerre reprendre la guerre à
l'ouest et bien là on avait besoin d'un
coup de fouet et disent certains des
amis de 'canaris' c'est la gestapo qui a
fait le coup alors là disons que nous
pouvons peut-être rester sceptique parce
que imaginer à hedrich par exemple
faisant installer une machine infernale
et acceptant de gaieté de coeur que
hitler soit à côté pendant tout son
discours
bien sûr la machine devait éclater plus
tard mais admettez qu'elle se détache
cette machine on ne pouvait pas courir
un tel risque
disons que jusqu'à plus ample informé
c'est une thèse qu'il est difficile
d'admettre et pourtant et pourtant
car cette affaire est pleine de clair
obscur avec plus de cure que de claire
et pourtant il y a quelque chose de bien
étrange encore elle sert je les dis a
été envoyé dans deux camps de
concentration
d'abord sachsenhausen oranienburg est un
peu plus tard d'art et là il a rencontré
des codétenus et chose curieuse il a
trouvé best vous savez l'anglais le
fameux selon soi-disant complices il le
sort a voulu que ces deux hommes se
retrouvent en camps de concentration et
puis il a rencontré plus tard aussi le
pasteur niemöller le fameux résistants
allemands et il aura fait le même récit
à tous les deux leur a dit voilà j'avais
été arrêté pendant l'été de 1939 comme
sympathisant communiste et un jour deux
étrangers sont venus j'étais à darou
deux étrangers sont venus me parler et
m'a dit voilà nous voulons faire mourir
des gens de la suite de hitler qui ont
trahi
nous avons besoin de faire sauter une
bombe à la bürger brao keller après que
hitler sera parti voulez-vous la
fabrique et si vous la fabriquer vous
aurez la liberté nouveau conduiront à la
frontière suisse
et là vous donnant l'argent vous serez
libre et riche alors raconté le cerf
j'ai accepté qu'on fasse qu'on tue des
conflits de hitler ça n'avait rien qui
puisse me chagrine et j'ai fabriqué la
bombe à d'aran et puis là quand elle a
été faite c'était au mois de novembre
m'emmener à munich on m'a conduit à la
bürger brao keller on m'a conduit au
pilier où déjà la cavité été ménagé et
là j'ai introduit le bon
et piles mes amis m'ont conduit jusqu'à
la frontière
ils m'ont laissé du monde donnait
l'argent malheureusement j'ai été pris
par les douaniers voilà donc l'histoire
qu'elle sert raconté dans ces deux camps
de concentration et elle est troublante
elle a troublé beaucoup d'historiens
quand vous lisez certaines histoires du
national socialisme c'est cette thèse là
que vous voyez là la plus répandue notam
ment ou liane shearer a été très ébranlé
par ce récit ce deuxième récit delserre
le pasteur niemöller lui qu'il a
entendus affirme c'est un récit qui a
toutes les apparences de la vérité est
pourtant ne devons pas être ébranlé par
ce réseau ce récit est faux parce que ce
récit peut séduire si on ne connaît pas
les interrogatoires delsert et tout le
dossier qui est aux archives de coblence
ce dossier formelle et tous ces témoins
lé logeuse ils n'étaient pas dans du
tout dans un camp de concentration
pendant l'été 39,0 était à munich on a
les adresses on a les gens qui l'ont vu
on ne sait que les sommes qu'ils paient
pour son loyer on connaît tous les gens
qui l'ont vu il ya tous les témoins qui
l'ont vu à la brasserie c'est un homme
qui est resté pendant des semaines et
des semaines et des semaines à munich
alors alors il est possible qu'elle
serre ait voulu tout à coup embellir son
récit en captivité il était avec des
hommes de coeur des patriotes des
résistants et tout à coup il a voulu se
poser en victime de la gestapo alors que
son histoire mon dieu se suffit à
elle-même
pourquoi enjoliver on ne saura jamais
qui pourrait nous donner la solution de
cette version nouvelle
alors il faut rester sur la version de
cet homme seul qui travaille seul
encore un point j'allais l'oublier parce
que vous y pensez le billet et oui le
billet le billet qu'on a passée à hitler
pendant le discours bien c'était
simplement un message de gorille qui
rappelait à hitler qu'il avait rendez
vous le lendemain matin avec lui à 10h à
berlin avec un savant allemand et qu'il
fallait absolument le voir que c'était
capital qu'il fallait par conséquent
qu'il n'oublie pas de prendre le train
leur c'était aussi simple que ça
quelquefois on remet un mystère devant
ce qui n'est que les mantais ce qui
reste mystérieux et ce sera mon dernier
mystère rassurez vous c'est le
traitement de choix qui fut réservé à
elle sert aussi bien à sachsenhausen cas
d'aran ne pensez pas qu'on lui ait donné
le sinistre pyjama rayé qu'il ait été
casser des cailloux qu'ils aient eu les
rations avec lesquels on mourait si vite
pas du tout il était dans un quartier à
part la housse élevé deux petites villes
là c'est là que avaient été reçus paul
reynaud edouard herriot les chanceliers
schultz nique le prince héritier de
bavière et là il avait lui aussi sa
petite maison on lui avait donné un
complet de bonnes confection il avait
même un domestique
on lui avait ouvert un atelier de
menuiserie parce qu'il fallait bien
qu'ils s'occupent cet homme et toute la
journée il faisait la menuiserie en
chantant
c'était même construit une petite sitar
et jouer de la cithare on l'appelle
homme à la cites en 44 il est à dar au
même traitement même maison à part même
atelier de menuiserie
même si tu as alors pourquoi comment
alors certains sont tenté d'expliquer ça
logiquement en se disant vous voyez bien
c'est le complice des ide riches
il a rendu service à idriss et himmler
il a agi comme agent d'exécution de la
gestapo voyant c'est un argument qui se
retourne complètement les gens qui
avaient servi de cette manière là la
gestapo
mais ces gens-là mouret on ne le sait
pas vivre non probablement l'explication
est beaucoup plus bizarre elle a été
formulée par gizeh view qui a connu tout
ce personnel visé view qui a dit mais
pour hitler l air et l homme
par qui il devait mourir lui hitler et
part qu'il n'était pas mort en quelque
sorte sa vie s'identifier à sorte à la
vie des lasers par conséquent tant que l
air serait vivant et bien lui heatley
regarderai la vie c'est un raisonnement
fou mais tout est tellement fou dans la
nationale socialiste
c'est probablement là aussi la vérité
elle sert aurait pu peut être échappé à
cette apocalypse à ce cataclysme qui
s'étaient déchaînés sur le monde et
l'allemagne mais le 5 avril 1945 un coup
de téléphone arrive à la roue c'est
himmler qui n'a pas oublié
himmler qui sait que tout s'écroule que
les russes approche de berlin que les
alliés sont sur l'elbe que bientôt
russes et américains vont se rejoindre à
torgau c'est fini il clair se terre dans
son bunker à berlin et femmes auraient
alors himmler ne veut pas que d'autres
échappent alors que le chef femme aurait
elle donne l'ordre d'exécuter l2 12
officiers du camp fritz et landser vont
le chercher dans sa menuiserie lui dise
viens avec nous au crématoire guen porte
a réparé il le laisse au crématoire
il a de css l'un de ses bourreaux et
c'est cela tout à coup un souvenir de
reconnaissance à l'égard de cet homme
qui jouait si bien la cithare il va
chercher la sita et revient au
crématoire
il pousse la porte et là il voit
simplement le cadavre de guerre qu'elle
sert la nuque fracasser sur le chariot
de fer devant l'énorme feu qui roule
alors il pose la cithare sur le corps
delsert et lcr et sa cithare vont brûler
ensemble de la sentimentalité chez les
ss
voilà le titre de cet épisode
voilà l'histoire deux joergensen alors
là tout mais on doit se dire que tout ça
a tenu à bien peu de choses il ne s'est
écoulé que 12 minutes entre le moment où
hitler quitter l'as berck herbe rang
keller est le moment où la bombe a
éclaté
douze minutes alors et si la bombe avait
éclaté à temps himmler goebel c'était là
dans la brasserie à dieu himmler adieu
goebbels d'après la constitution du
troisième reich 7 et göring il succédé
goering dont il faut bien reconnaître
que quelques mois plus tôt il avait
essayé de sauver la paix négociant
jusqu'au dernier moment avec les anglais
par l'intermédiaire de dalé rousse alors
green et c'est très possible ré essayer
de renouer les négociations et peut-être
mais refaire l'histoire mais peut-être
tout à coup le monde se serait-il
épargné quelques dizaines de millions de
morts d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
sont jezzy 12 minutes
[Musique]